[Music]
on July 13 1944 William James cidus's
landlord found him unconscious in his
small Boston boarding house he had
suffered a massive stroke and laid dying
William may have been the smartest
person who ever lived his IQ was
somewhere between 250 and 300. to put
that in perspective Einstein's was
estimated to be 200. William's parents
were brilliant Ukrainian Jewish
immigrants borisitis was a renowned
psychologist sarasitis went to medical
school at a time when few women did
William or Billy as he was known learned
the Alphabet by six months of age at 18
months he could read the New York Times
he enrolled at Harvard University at age
11. when he graduated William told
reporters he intended to live the
perfect life but that would not come to
be
William James Sidis was born on April
Fool's Day 1898 in New York City violent
anti-semitic attacks in Ukraine which
was then part of the Russian Empire
drove his parents to the promised land
where they met when Boris tutored Sarah
in English she encouraged him to go to
Harvard where he studied psychology and
used some of his psychological
principles to help mold his son he said
you know the old saying as The Twig is
bent the trees inclined parents cannot
too soon begin the work of bending the
minds of their children in the right
direction
William's parents attributed his
extraordinary intelligence not to jeans
but to his upbringing they treated him
like an adult when he was a few months
old William's parents placed food and a
spoon in front of him they let him
observe and he learned to feed himself
his mum recalled he squealed with
delight no one had taught him he had
reasoned it out this natural way of
reasoning is also how his parents taught
him to spell instead of learning through
memorization William learned to spell by
focusing on the underlying patterns and
structures for example if he learned the
word bat using letter blocks then he
understood that modifying the word by
say swapping at the a for an e would
form a new word with a different meaning
in the way that he learned to spell
William learned eight Languages by the
age of eight by understanding the
fundamental principles of language
structure besides English he knew Latin
Greek German Russian Hebrew Turkish
French and Armenian he even invented his
own language as a child vendor good
which Drew on European influences
instead of reading him fairy tales at
bedtime his parents read in Greek myths
which helped him learn about the planets
Jupiter is named after the Roman god
Jupiter which is adapted from Zeus in
Greek mythology
every moment was an opportunity to learn
William had no desire for or interest in
playing with toys he didn't play sports
or any games at recess his father
thought such childish Pursuits were
Silly and meaningless William also had a
tremendous fear of dogs good girl
good girl his only enjoyment was riding
on streetcars when his parents took him
to museums libraries parks and zoos he
collected 1600 streetcar transfers by
the time he was in his 20s William ended
up finishing elementary school in less
than one year in high school in six
weeks his mom remarked the newspapers
never missed a chance to try and prove
that he was insane or psychotic or
simply a freak in truth Billy was a
completely normal child in every respect
the media attention followed him to
Harvard where they portrayed him as a
know-it-all like in this New Yorker
cartoon where he's lecturing to a group
of men
after entering Harvard at age 11 he gave
a lecture to the math club about the
fourth dimension which is an extension
beyond the 3D space we experience here
he's talking about shapes with many
sides in the fourth dimension which
demonstrates his astounding ability to
comprehend complex mathematical Concepts
Beyond his ears a professor at MIT who
attended the lecture proclaimed I
predict that youngsitis will be a great
astronomical mathematician
yet this never happened in fact he would
grow to resent mathematics
shortly after the lecture he fell ill
which made all the news the media
reported that he had suffered a mental
breakdown which was a rumor that dogged
him his entire life
he did live with his family on an estate
in New Hampshire that was also the
grounds of the sanatorium Boris was
running William only returned to Harvard
several months later and never fit in
his biographer Amy Wallace described how
he was quote a complete freak in the
eyes of his fellow students he had none
of the social graces no interest in
sports or girls and was several years
younger when he graduated from Harvard
he told reporters I want to live the
perfect life the only way to live the
perfect life is to live it in seclusion
I've always hated crowds his idea of the
perfect life is described in a paper he
wrote about a utopian society called
Hesperia hisperia's Constitution began
with We the People reminiscent of the
U.S Constitution but that is where the
similarities end in Hesperia those who
want citizenship have to pass an
intelligence test marriage is forbidden
while polygamy is completely legal
interestingly children are not raised by
their biological parents and instead
male children shall be assigned to the
charge of male Guardians and female
children to the charge of female
Guardians he rejected the influence of
his parents particularly that of his
domineering mother
after leaving Harvard he took up a
position teaching mathematics at Rice
Institute now Rice University in Houston
he was 17 years old just like at Harvard
William didn't fit in at Rice students
teased him for never having kissed a
girl girls faked crushes on him as a
joke he stayed at rice for only eight
months and then enrolled at Harvard Law
School in the fall of 1916. then for
some unknown reason he quit in his last
semester his mother was Furious and
would tell people that her son left his
studies because Harvard Law had shut
down due to World War one which was not
true William was very much anti-war he
refused to register for the draft and
nearly went to prison if it weren't for
the Armistice of 1918 that ended the
first world war he was extremely
passionate about politics he was briefly
jailed after leading a Mayday rally in
Boston an anti-war workers rights rally
organized by the Socialists that turned
violent he rebelled against the
capitalist system that propelled his
parents from their status as poor
immigrants to a position of success in
American society
while in jail he met and fell head over
heels for Martha Foley a 20 year old
Irish girl who grew up in Boston despite
telling the Boston Herald earlier that
he vowed to remain celibate saying women
do not appeal to me
after the arrest he followed Martha to
New York they kissed but Martha assured
him there would be nothing more
Williams unrequited love may have
affected the trajectory of his life
William's friend Julius eichel said
cytus admitted that her love might have
achieved wonders with him
he carried a photograph of her in his
pocket until the day he died
Martha went on to marry a writer and
achieved notoriety for co-founding the
literary Magazine's story
when her memoirs were published she
briefly mentioned William in a single
line in which she called him the famous
and tragic Prodigy who was the first boy
ever to pay court to me
despite his Brilliance William failed to
achieve greatness and any work that did
show promise was overlooked in 1925 he
published a book that challenged the
second law of Thermodynamics the
principle that the universe is headed
toward heat death where all energy is
evenly spread out so there won't be any
energy left to power any processes in
this state nothing will move change or
live
in the animate and the inanimate he
explored the possibility of reversing
the universe's Direction
he theorized that living things could
tap into a hidden source of energy to
counteract the process he gave an
example of a ball bouncing down the
stairs which when played in Reverse
appears as if a hidden source of energy
is pushing the ball up the stairs he did
acknowledge that his work was
speculative and his theory has never
been proven but it was never taken
seriously in the first place it was
ignored there wasn't a single review
during its time
he made headlines for being a boy
Prodigy and for his private life yet no
one paid attention to his academic work
he stopped writing about physics math
and cosmology altogether
while in New York he took on menial jobs
including working as an operator at an
office that was using an early
mechanical calculator called a
comptometer the papers were all too Keen
to Splash the headlines About the Boy
Wonder earning an average wage of 23
bucks a week
he hid his genius from his co-workers
when they found out who he was he'd move
on to the next job he refused to accept
higher paying work in which he had to
use his intellect once he was offered a
job with a railway company who tried to
put him to work solving their technical
problems one of the officials later
found him crying William told him he
couldn't bear the thought of doing math
another time a cousin needed his math
skills to help solve a dental problem
involving the alignment of teeth he
offered William three thousand dollars
the equivalent of 55 000 today it would
have taken him two hours to solve but he
refused William's biographer concludes
he could not take a job of complex
figuring without risking emotional and
physical illness
his entire life had been defined by
pressure to perform at a high level at
the expense of mastering basic life
skills he confessed to an aunt that he
had never been taught to tie his
shoelaces his parents may have provided
him with an exceptional education yet
they failed to teach him the basics of
grooming he didn't shave regularly wore
a worn out cap he reportedly didn't
bathe or at least not often and the
stench was said to be brutal when his
father suffered a stroke and died in
October 1923 he never attended the
funeral according to William's
biographer the reason was that he
refused to see his mum William hated
that she dominated him as a child the
statuses didn't raise their other child
with the same intensity William's
younger sister Helena did not get a
formal Elementary or high school
education Helena said that her father
had become so fed up with William that
he didn't want to educate her she was
also seriously ill as a child
nonetheless she thrived under the
guidance of her brother who taught her
how to read and write and she passed the
entrance exams to attend University
in his 30s Williams settled in Boston
again doing menial jobs the media had a
Heyday when they found out he was
working as a lowly office clerk an
unflattering article in a Boston Daily
Newspaper read William J Sidis now 39
was once declared by a group of eminent
scientists to be a coming innovator in
the field of science with potentialities
as great as Einstein and as brilliant as
Marconi yet yesterday a Sunday
Advertiser writer found him in a small
room wallpapered in dark where for the
past five years he has lived unknown
unsung uncaring
his health had also started to decline
he was overweight and had high blood
pressure which eventually caused a
stroke the kind that claimed his father
on July 17 1944 William James cidus died
of a cerebral hemorrhage which led to
pneumonia he was 46 years old he was
buried beside his father in New
Hampshire
William didn't achieve the level of
success of prominence expected of
someone so brilliant was it because his
parents pushed him too far a faculty
member at Rice University where William
briefly taught disagreed Dr Gerard
believes he was the victim not of
intensive education given by his father
nor of the Romantic curse called genius
but of the thoughtless cruelty of the
public
the New York Times once excitedly
described William as a wonderfully
successful result of a scientific
foreseeing experiment and as such
furnishes one of the most interesting
mental phenomena in history
as we now know early success did not
guarantee a fulfilling and successful
life
if William had a different upbringing
the outcome of his life might have been
entirely different one thing that's
certain is his exceptional Mastery of
Science and Mathematics if you'd like to
sharpen your skills in stem I recommend
brilliant.org a website and app where
you can answer puzzling questions like
this a cup of warm water is suspended in
a large pot of water held at a steady
boil will the water in the cup ever boil
assume the large pot never runs out of
water the answer is that it will never
boil as the cup of water heats up to 100
degrees Celsius in The Boiling Pot heat
flow stops since both are at the same
temperature brilliant can enhance your
scientific thinking computer science and
math skills no matter your skill level
giving you an edge in today's
competitive Marketplace I use brilliant
to go through their logic courses which
have improved my analytical thinking you
can try out brilliant for free for 30
days by heading to the custom link in my
description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up with my link will get
20 off their premium subscription which
gives you access to all the offerings
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm
foreign